usually what I like to show discusses
advance endings and today we're going to
look at some of the concepts of pon
enemies that I think are not only
instructive and maybe sometimes
complicated but that I think they're
also very pretty and beautiful but in
order for this to work properly my first
question is does anybody or everybody
here know how to win or draw King and
one pawn versus King how many you are
familiar with that with our concept like
if I put a king and a pawn on the board
and two kings in a poem one side has a
pawn no matter how I set them up you
will immediately know if it's a win or a
draw how many of you think that they're
confident of that
with one point King in one point okay
most of you okay so for the sake of
doing a proper job I am going to just
very super quickly deal with that so for
example the position like this should be
one known no matter who is on the move
this is always a draw by going down the
board why because black is a very simple
strategy of weighting opposing until the
board ends so if it would have been
black to move you would have just played
a waiting move if it's right to move
he's gonna place a move black Waits
I wouldn't wait this way I always want
to wait this way when white eventually
has to show himself
we oppose check block have to defend the
pawn waiting move eventually you have to
make progress opposed check block defend
your pawn until we get to the end of the
board after which this is stomach so
this is very very easy the next position
okay now the right to move is very
important because whoever's on the move
that means it is opponent just gained
the opposition and opposition is when
the Kings opposite one another with one
square or uneven number of squares close
opposition is one square this in
opposition is another odd number three
or five or seven in this case of course
this is
like to move and that's gonna be a draw
why because he's gonna go it's one side
let's say and you're gonna oppose and if
we dance excuse me if we dance like this
with our Kings we can do this forever
let cetera eventually like this to push
this pawn and then when the King blocks
what do we have the very same position
we'd show before when the King in front
behind is born or on the same level of
his pawn is the same thing you'd have to
advance and I'm gonna wait and you have
to show and that's the standard we saw
before if this however would have been
black to move you would have lost so
let's pretend for a moment that I'm
gonna play badly for black just to show
and here here here already you can see
it when black would choose one side
white would choose the other and
eventually the pawn will march in all
the way to the Queen Square okay do we
understand that okay one last thing to
talk about is that if the pawn let's say
is on d2 if you can imagine the pawn
here then the right to move does not
matter anymore
because white always has a temper if
it's his move he gains the opposition
and if it's black to move he's just
clearing the way the path to the pawn
like we saw before you just have to
count it's a very simple task of
counting so with that in mind this is
very relevant to some of the positions
we see today that's why I have to start
with that so we are going to start with
actually something that's kind of funny
it has nothing to do with Portland
things right but this is a good lesson
if you want to teach someone a position
this is a great way to teach someone the
opposition of course we know that this
is a win for white because here's an
extra rock right but this position comes
with a a prerequisite and that is white
can only move his rook once you can only
move you rock once you're not allowed to
move you look more than one time so
basically you got it only gonna move it
when you deliver checkmate if you touch
it before you squandered your chances so
as you can see right now one two three
four five six even number of squares
between the king and the two kings so
white starts by gaining a distant
opposition now there are five squares so
in an odd number of squares between the
Kings and now you
Black has some dilemmas for example King
b8 is what he played if he was to play
let's say King to be seven then what
would I do
where would I go you know to have it and
an odd number let's say I go here okay
King b3 and after each squares and we
are making progress and you will see
that this is the way you're gonna push
the King to the corner let's try it with
the most the best the best fight that
black can offer King b8 and white plays
King meteor so now you might be
wondering wait a minute how is this
going to lead to anything because he's
always gonna dance and let's see he's
gonna go to a8 if he goes to a 7
they're likely the clean case of King b3
we go here and then here here and again
we get to the same position just one
rank up which is gonna happen anyways so
after king b8 King b2 King a 8 now white
uses his C file King c5 he just again he
flanks this is one of the things with
opposition if you imagine this is a pawn
between the Kings you always want to be
and under when you're trying to win when
you're on the winning side when your
opponent goes one way you want to go
another way
and then you clear the path that upon
here there's no point but there's just
opposition so again what can you do in
the case of King a7 excuse me then you
just go King c4 you just keep climbing
on the C file then you're gonna just
outflank it and the rook is gonna give
mate on the a file so that's easy let's
pretend if King goes to b7
now what move should reply again distant
opposition is measured by an uneven and
odd number of squares between the Kings
yes yes King to b3 I'm sure all of you
thought about that
now there's an onion an odd number of
squares between the Kings so what can
the King dear king a7 let's say and now
we march king c4 again because staying
on the same place is not gonna work if
you're gonna go King a [ __ ] hero king
here then the King is just going to
oppose you and then it's gonna be a
dance like this forever
if you try to cross it's going to cross
the line right now the King is
things in this room so okay King b8 and
now raise your hand raise your hands if
you want to say you King - before once
again an odd number of squares between
the Kings that's how you gained your
position so King a84 was King c5 again I
have to go to the C file because if I go
eh if I go to a four he's gonna go to b8
what did I achieve nothing he's not
gonna go up and if I go up he's gonna
oppose me
so now so again he went one way we're
clearing the way this way
eventually he goes here now it becomes
really easy king b5 only one square
between them that's the classical
classic opposition and now two choices
you can go here you can go backwards
we'll just chase him here we're just
gonna go king c6 again you ready you
notice how one flank we choose the other
if he goes King a6 rook a one is mate so
he has got a play King b8 if he goes
with King a eight then King c7 and next
move it's made on a1 so he's gotta go
King b8 and now I'm sure everybody could
see this move we pushed him to the edge
of the board he has one legal move and
checkmate again a very nice puzzle if
you think about it it's instructive not
because it's cute I mean it is cute kind
of you can move your rock I mean that's
not already a just rule but when you
want to teach so on the opposition this
is a great exercise they enjoy
themselves it's kind of a challenging
trick it's beyond chess it's logic and
you also learn about the opposition okay
so we are going to eliminate this one
and our next puzzle is going to be this
yeah this is a position for a very
famous game between capablanca and
Edward Lasker not Emmanuel Oscar who was
world champion for 27 years but Edward
Lasker Alaska and here at Lasker with
black could have held that draw against
his opponent of course he understands
that in this position forget about the
number of the pawns White has two pawns
running down the board right here you
better find a way to stop them and he
didn't
he just he understood it he has to stop
them but he didn't do it in the most
efficient way okay in the game he played
the move kingi five two question marks
and the reason is he probably thought
well what's gonna happen if the King
moves away from my pawn great if he
pushes the Jeep one that I'm just gonna
take and go King of six and wind up on
maybe even win the game because they
have an extra pawn but all of a sudden
he saw the move eight six and now the
king cannot cross anymore because of his
own pawn and the f1 and there's no way
to stop g6 and winning so we had to
resign he lost if you would have been a
little more careful he would have seen
it after the simple move King e6 King
takes here f4 he keeps the White King
busy simply by selling his own pawn and
after here here here here he reaches the
pawns after g6 takes if you play eight
six I'm stopping the pawn so probably
white would have to take the pawn on g6
and then of course with a rook pawn we
know it would be a very simple draw you
will see why this is important in a
second I'm going to show you more
positions that are somewhat relevant to
that now we're gonna see another
position by the way any questions I
might be going too fast tell me if I'm
going too fast and also please tell me
if you have any questions on the
position but I'm sure that in this
position you on the device understood
the difference between King II 5 where
he gets stuck because this one just
doesn't move is this one that moves and
then who cares about losing a point if
you're about to make a queen well this
move would have just taken care of
everything like after this if he does
this of course we have this move this is
only a way for white to lose not to win
because he's gonna lose all pond ok so
we look at this position we think to
ourselves well each side has a king in a
pawn looks a bit messy and close that
quite as the outside passport on the a
file but we know it's a rough one
and also it seems like the king is in
the box what does this mean that the
king has no more than four squares
between in the pond so if the port just
marches in a four King here a five king
here a six King here a seven King here
I'm stopping the pawn very easy right I
cannot just run with my pawn so white
needs to use another system and you'll
see that white does it in a very elegant
way King f5 very very logical he is
stopping the King from coming on the
diagonal that saves the pawn and also
preventing him from running respond but
everything has to be very accurate
because as you will notice and that
something else I should have actually
asked you and that is to tell you that
many times the Queen ending when the
Queen once that has a queen and the
other one has a pawn either on the rook
file a7 h7h two and A two and or or the
bishop file c7 f7 f2 and seat you if the
pawn is on the seventh ring it's very
hard to win many times it's a draw if
your king is not close enough it's going
to be a draw because of stalemate
possibilities like if you can imagine if
my king my black King is here in the
corner and the White Queen takes this
pawn it's a stalemate you cannot easily
wind up on or in exchange if my King
gets to the corner with the rook pawn
and I have a pawn here and there's a
king here you have to always you cannot
just jail me here forever and bring your
king because it will be a stalemate do
you guys understand what should I show
you I'll show you her so a position like
this is a draw why is it a draw because
well here white of course will Queen but
let's pretend I just make a move to turn
the path past the turn for black when
you make a move like this for black and
I moved it normally will do one of two
things either wind upon or force you to
block the pawn in which case the King
just slowly advances that's what happens
if the pawn is here here here or here
but in this position I can afford to
play here I'm just telling you well
about to Queen my phone you want to take
it take it and it's still made you
understand if the king is close well you
will select it place at a plate you can
play a part
another thing to remember so this is
also a draw the King is too far and the
reason now is because after let's say
check King here normally when he blocked
the pond the black King can advance but
now it's gonna be stomach so there is no
way to both stop me from queening the
pawn and forcing me to block it so the
King can advance the key can advance so
now if you make a key move it's done it
and any Queen move that breaks the
stalemate let's say here then I'm just
going here and I'm quitting the pawn so
that's why these are drawn now why is it
relevant to our appeal to our position
you will see in a second white goes King
a 5 King III only move kingi 5 and now
he has to play C 6 if you play King B 3
then after King D 5 King C 5 and my
point now I just blocked your pawn and
there is no way to stop the a-train
a-four a-five a-six a-seven a-eight i
make a new queen that is just academic
that's very simple so in this position
he needs to play the move c 6 now he
doesn't let the king cross but his own
king wants to keep the chase going so
now i plays a 4 what else is left king
d3 a5 of course the king already missed
that boat he cannot stop the pawn but
now he can push his own pawn but it cost
him dear time a 6 C 4 a 7 C 3 a 8 Queen
c2 now all we need is like one more move
with our King closer and it's going to
be a draw so if you let's say if you go
Queen a1 trying to stop the Queen from
the pond from queening I'm gonna go King
b2 that's already a draw forget it you
cannot win anymore is that understood
yeah this is very very annoying so also
other moves are gonna be tricky because
where are you going to go but look at
the way he wins he wins it a very nice
where he goes Queen d5 check this is the
most important way to win now
all the king moves are really really bad
for example that's examined the moves
the main line goes King III will see it
last
if King c3 simply check and here once
you do that once you take away that
quitting square from the axis of the
King then of course it's winning because
my queen is just gonna stay here forever
and then my king is gonna come close
close close and the pond is gonna be
lost even if my king is like as far away
as here but that's easy win
alternatively after king e to again a
beautiful way to remember how to win
Queen a to pinning the pawn the king has
to go to d1 otherwise the pawn will stay
pinned and now the beautiful part comes
king d4 you make a queen king d3 and
even though it's king and queen versus
king and queen there is no way that you
can stop mate there is no way I'm
threatening mate on e2 and any Queen
move excuse me any Queen move that you
will notice will lead to mate either and
the back rank of course or one of those
squares so it's winning totally winning
position good to memorize this kind of
position because this occurs a lot
lastly after the aforementioned check if
King III now comes a really beautiful
idea again a beautiful concept because
well he wants to Queen if the Queen
tries to take care of it somehow then
the King is gonna drop back and threaten
the Queen again so for example Queen a2
doesn't work as it's not pin is gonna
Queen if you go Queen C for I'm just
gonna go P and eat you and if you let me
run all the way to the corner and give
you that one that's exactly what I would
like to do but in this position and if
the viewers of home want to kind of try
it so pause the video because I'm about
to show them look beautiful move
beautiful concept Queen GTO just a very
elegant trick and the point is that
after the pawn queens well of course if
the King moves away I'm gonna play the
same move so if here I'm just gonna
check skewing the king in the Queen
bye-bye Queen and alternatively if you
try to save it by playing King d3 I'm
gonna play here and like I said before
one
say occupy the square and Yuki cannot
get there it's lost next move I'm going
to play between here to see one so let's
see a play here trying to come here I'm
playing here beautiful and ignites
composition again review it very very
super quickly in this position white
rushes and black must stop the King this
cost him time and now the important
Czech Queen to d5 and we saw that
there's three different motifs one the
Queen gets immediately to control that
square the other one the Queen pins the
pawn and the King comes closer and
there's a mate nap and the third one
when the Queen a text upon and there is
a skewer on the long diagonal understood
oh I know these are advanced but this is
this is the kind of endings we're doing
today advanced concepts in pawn endings
okay the next position is again by the
same composer again a very beautiful
idea when you look at this position you
think yourself well this is an obvious
pawn race each side has an outside pass
ball or like a distant past pawn and it
looks like white is to play g4 and then
B 5 g 5 V 4 B 3 I mean g6 B 3 check the
King has to move then B 2 and then you
Queen first and white roll Queen we
check that's just going to be a draw so
let's examine it here here here here
here check I better go away advance here
Queen Queen check and draw I could just
go Queen b3 if I want to just if it's
just a draw but white is not interested
in the drawing this position because he
has a beautiful trick watch what he does
he does what we call a little staircase
trick he goes up and then he goes down
and watch why first of all he goes here
yeah I mean out of them king a3 I don't
know what else to suggest now just want
to March my Jeep on forever and your be
pond is stuck if you go b5 I'm just
going to go King before then the pawn is
stuck and there's nowhere you can stop
my pony to
for so you must come to support your
porn now I plays King c-4 again teasing
is about to go king b5 and take this
pawn so forced that's the up part and
now we start marching here it looks a
little illogical because of the Czech
tempo but yet when you will see you will
understand so check King d3 again a very
cunning move not King c3 when after king
a3 there's gonna be another check but we
just want to go this way this time we're
going to block the pawn so if you push
the pawn I'm gonna go here if you go
here I'm gonna go here and now again you
cannot stop my pawn and my King you're
just standing there like an annoying
guard bouncer right so after king d3
king a3 again he has suspended tempo g5
before g6 b3 g7 b 2 he's ready to clean
with check but what do we do we again go
back pretending that we stopping the
pawn and when the black king is lured to
this diagonal we couldn't we check and
winning very aesthetic when I look into
suddenly I've seen it so many times
every time I see it I feel like it's
really beautiful just a beautiful way it
looks like with only 2 points left on
the board how much life there is to this
position again you don't just rush with
the pawn but you first you bring your
king up which is somewhat
counterintuitive then you go down but
you have to be careful not to allow
checks and then you lure the king to the
point where the Queen Queens we check
now black is not gonna get to save his
pawn of course after King a3 we can just
win the pawn oh it's checkmate actually
even easier the computer was smarter
than me yeah okay on we go let's
eliminate this one and now let's see
which one did I want to show first oh
this one yeah this is nice
again a beautiful beautiful idea
importantly when you look at the
position at first and I have to tell you
when I saw it many many years ago I was
in panic I thought to myself what a mess
how can I even count
there's so many legal moves I could play
a million porn moves I can play King
moves how can I even reach the solution
here and then I said to myself like I
always tell my students again please ask
yourself the right questions what did
you want to do what does your opponent
want to do what must you prevent and it
becomes very very obvious again if we
had a very long lecture of many many
hours I could just let you think about
it and we try to solve it but instead
let me guide you to it one thing is that
if white is going to do something well
if white is white to move and win why
would we win I mean this point is not
past this point is not past this bun is
not past but the a pond is past if I can
somehow get this guy to here that would
be quite nice however black has his own
threats and one would be very wise to
pay attention to those positions because
if I'm rushing with my pawn and he's
gonna let's say take it on Poisson and
take now I'm ready to again roam again
he is gonna go King here and all of a
sudden I'm losing because after a 4 h5 a
5h for la la la Nate
oopsie big accident so now we understand
the pole on g2 has to go definitely has
to go part now we see another unknowing
thing if we take the pole immediately
and the King starts running for the
defense then he stops the port look
after a four takes takes and he goes
king f6 a for king here here here he's
in the box
he stops the pond how frustrating really
really annoying who wants him to stop
the pawn it's really yes ok wait a
second where it is saying what we're
trying to be not we're not in
competition now we are just trying to
explain it so we learned two things that
are very important one we cannot rush
with our pond first because we're gonna
get maded two we cannot eliminate this
pond immediately because the king is
going to have a route to escape
therefore by
of elimination we understand that we
have to because we're gonna have a new
queen if we have a new queen anything
else we can sacrifice right we don't
need all the riffraff right there's a
collateral damage so step one f6 at
first if I play this move without
explaining you would say Aviv we
drinking or what
what is this giving a pawn for no reason
but now you guys understand I'm killing
two birds with one stone again I'm not
getting made it because my pawn is super
fast there is no time to play King g3
and pushing gauge but I'm gonna make a
queen and kill him way before and on the
other hand I'm already taking away the
escape route from the king so f6 he's
gotta take it and now again King g3 is
threatening so I gotta take the pawn
beautiful so step one has been achieved
we have eliminated they are knowing G
pond and it's not easy for black to stop
our pawn now but he's gonna try King g5
and now a for like expected the pawn
starts running but it's not so simple
of course he's slowing it down by taking
a pass on and we take back again the a
pawn the a-train is ready to move so he
goes King here now again we noticed that
that FA for King e5 a 5 takes a6 King c6
he stopped the pond he took our porn
he's gonna stop our pawn he's gonna win
that's not very good so what do we do
a4 king e5 and now we must interject
something we must do something because
I'm a 5 he just takes it so no good
so what should we do should we push the
D pawn or should we push the C pawn what
do you guys think I want you to really
stop and think for a second because one
of them wins the other one loses yes
okay but then what do you think white
will do I mean black will do
I can take it because you're gonna go a5
right I mean after c6 if I take it
you're gonna go a 5 and you achieved
exactly what you wanted upon marxism but
if you go c6 I'm gonna go d6 and after
a5 King takes d5 a6 King takes c6 what
happened I stopped the pawn I reached it
right so the correct continuation is to
play d6 now he's stuck because I'm about
to take his pawn if you go c6 now you
won't be able to cross in time so he's
gotta take
and again it's time to be very accurate
because a5 King defy stops the pawn so
he gives up and not a pawn
beautiful and after pawn takes a 5 and
the pond Queens so at the end of the
exercise black is up three pawns but
here's a little problem you cannot stop
the pawns the one point that I have left
so again from the top we understand
what's going on we want to Queen our
outside passer we don't want to get made
it and smothered by this king in his
pawns what do we do we can't push the
pond immediately we can't get rid of the
polimedia because he stops our pond so
we interfere with his escape route after
here here and now been giving up two
points to take away the two squares the
King so desperately needed in order to
try to stop our pawns upon understood
great any questions before I get rid of
it or okay our next position is going to
be related to break through and let's
start with this one okay for now it's
not yet upon ending but it's going to be
come upon ending here when you look at
this position this position is now sold
and I showed some kids that I'm teaching
and it's like this is a black to move
and win exercise if you look at the
position it's a bit confusing it's
obvious that black has a beautiful chain
of former pawns on the Queen side
proud night in the center the white
night on however is looking very sad of
the four possible squares that they can
go for from d1 to our zone pawns and two
are covered by the pawn the black pawn
so the knight is not moving however my
King is attacking and the White King is
attacking the Black Knight so the
question is what to do if you go back
then maybe this King is going to come
and save the day right it's going to
become an active King so black plays a
beautiful move that wins the game Knight
to c3 and again why because he
understands that by giving away this
night one of two things will happen
either he's going to win the white
knight because that knight cannot move
em it cannot be defended that's a big
problem on the other hand if he takes it
then is the pawn is just going to Queen
so if Knight takes Knight excuse me pawn
takes threatening the pawn if you take
I'm just gonna go a four there's no way
you can stop the a pawn I'm just
marching in in and in the king is just
too far some of you might say okay maybe
I can just take it with my pawn which is
what he did and black simply played a
four again marching with his pawn he's
about to Queen his pawn now what to do
how to stop the a pawn it's impossible
he tried to play C takes d4 now he's
really hoping maybe black will blunder
by rushing with this pawn and then
Knight c3 is gonna come and he's
blocking it right on time but black says
hey I can take the time to just take
back make sure that my pawn keeps you
really honest here you cannot stop and
of course now he is losing he tried to
play the move c3 again pray maybe maybe
by some America black will play D takes
c3 but of course black had none of that
simply marched his pawn and white had to
resign it was gonna be down the green
there's gonna be dollar Queenie just
about a second yeah did you understand
the concept of breakthrough let's see
more example of that and more examples
let's take a look at this game when you
look at the position you think
it looks to me like white is a pop one
on a few side and the rest of the pawns
look really blocked but sometimes we
only have double pawns that opens up the
door for a chance of a breakthrough in
the ponding and there are many examples
this is just one of them obviously the
black king is not about to move away and
let white try to quit his pawns that's
completely useless what he is going to
do is just use the pawns as they are to
create a passport
it might look impossible because you say
wait a minute how can you possibly cross
any point that you push I'm just going
to be able to take but the thing is all
you need is one poor left the Queen who
cares about the rest of the pond so he
played c4 beautiful it looks like a
crazy move what the heck how can you
play a move like this I can take it to
different on two different ways however
when you take a closer look you quickly
realize wait a minute this is just
amazing
I cannot take with a beep on that's kind
of obvious if I take with a beep on a4
and that a4 Express is going in so you
might ask wait a minute okay that's easy
to understand but what if I took with
the beep I took with a deep bond then
once again we are the ideas just to
create a breakthrough just to get one
pump to the today to do a touchdown and
you think yourself ok which is gonna be
the past pawn it cannot be this one and
cannot be this one it has to be this one
but if I push it and takes that's
nothing so push again I just want to
march in you gotta take it I'm pushing
the other pawn I'm sucking everything
and after takes d3 and I might be down
to four six seven four pawns but my pot
is about to become a queen and all your
pawns are too late they're too far my
queen is just gonna sweep them up and
win was that understood also I should
say some of you might still say after c4
Ken white play the move King g3 just not
touch the pawns and now of course any
capture is just going to lead to a dead
end
any capture is nothing but now black
simply insists on a pawn now I want to
go a3 and then I want to go a for a 2 so
he's gotta take
and now BAM just breaking the foundation
I'm threatening beat xe2
you better take me and then c3 once
again a pawn reaches the martyr square
again the king is too far
King f - C - King you - I make a new
queen beautiful a beautiful idea of
breakthrough is that understood or is
that equal are any questions ok one more
example of that is from a real game and
I found this really really cute in this
game the position should end in a draw I
mean this this game should end in a draw
you know honesty the black king is very
strong the white king is ok is just
enough he's just in time for stopping
him
so black decides one last trick he
retreats he just goes back you'll notice
that g4 or b4 just don't work or H but
don't work in that position
my King is just too close so what what
he does he lures the White King to come
further so white plays here here he
chases him and chases him so far
everything is good here and here and
here and why things hey I'm actually
gonna win because I'm corralling this
pawn and he played Kings g6 however this
is a losing blunder just when he thought
that now hey the King has no moves he
has to let go of the pawn and he's going
to lose now the White King is way way
too far in the other side of the world
vacationing and it's time for us to
break through step 1
g4 now we can see that this position
very much resembles the previous
position that we saw this is a great
pawn structure for a pawn break and you
can imagine that the H and F pawns are
going to play a key role in it he played
CC 5 what else
and now f4 again just like B
for a beautiful strike at the most
defended square we already understand
what's going on okay in the game he went
he takes f4 but what can he do if he was
if he was to play G pawn then H and we
know that the H part just marches him if
he was not to take either pawn and try
to run away or just make a move
somewhere then of course we will play
just like in the other game age for the
goal is clear
take everything you want I just want one
pawn queening and after takes g3 hitting
at the foundation and after this it's
winning after you take my porn I can
either take or advance doesn't matter
I'm just gonna make a new queen and win
the game so after this he took with the
e pawn and now h4 I'm about to go h3 so
takes g3 getting rid of the last
obstacle and then III just a beautiful
way of giving everything just for the
sake of making one Queen before we go
with a lot but the two last positions
that are the most difficult I'll show
you a position that I'm pretty sure most
of you already know but again it just
occurred to me now that I could have
shown at you as a first as a precursor
to all this when you see this position
and at first you think yourself okay
that has to be a draw each side has
three pawns each set has a king but that
is the simplest example of break free if
you want to teach someone break through
just showing this position with black to
move he would have drawn immediately by
playing this once I play this it's a
draw forget about it but it's right to
move he goes b6 and again there's a
problem you gotta take hit because I'm
about to take the opponent become a
queen if you take this way I'm gonna
whoops
not this way obviously I'm gonna push my
pawn
and when you have to take that or else
I'll take you my point marches in and
becomes a queen alternatively after b6
if you take like this then after a six
pawn takes c6 and this pawn marches on
so this is a simple way to teach even a
lower-end player about breakthrough okay
our last two positions again are very
very difficult but I I kind of love them
and this is again when we talked about
King and pawn versus King that's what I
was leading you to when you look at this
position you think to yourself each side
has only one point and one minor piece
left that's not a whole lot but one
thing is becoming very evident the
knight on a 8 looks really really
trapped if I'm gonna get to go King c8
King b7 King takes Knight I'm gonna win
the game easily especially because my
rook pawn and my bishops are on the same
Queenie's color the squealing square so
that's gonna be a win we're gonna easily
win this pawn pushed up King away from
the corner and Queen our pawn that is
easy white on the other hand has a very
simple concept he doesn't want to lose
his knight or he's saying okay if you
want to win my knight I want to charge
you your pawn I want to charge you your
last pond and this is where knowing King
and port landings is very important
because let's pretend that my system is
going to be to push the pawn to a4 for
example let's say and I'm gonna play
King CA I'm after the knight King pawn
here King here and now you say look my
knight comes out how beautiful however
no I'm not going to take with my pawn
and then it's gonna be a simple draw I'm
rather gonna take with my bishop and
after pawn takes pawn tips the computer
decided to place any man pawn takes and
block his winning why is he winning
because he's gonna have his King in
front of his bone just like we saw this
king is just too far south the King here
King here King here King here winning
just winning if you go King c3 I'm gonna
keep clearing the way to the pawn if
you're gonna go King here
I'm gonna go King here remember we
talked about that just moments ago and
when you choose one side I'm gonna go
the other I just have to calculate and
it's gonna go all the way to the Queenie
square all I have to do is always make
sure that the pole is not blocked that I
always have the opposition always choose
one side and leave your opponent with
the other so what to do
how do we draw it still it's a draw and
with a very beautiful way watch King d5
move 1 now my idea is if you go King c8
I'm gonna go king c6 and my knight is
gonna come out either from here or from
here and at a minimum I'm gonna get your
pawn or the nitrogen is going to come
out so he's gotta play King B 7 he has
to postpone capturing the night for a
moment and now he is opposite the king
he is hoping to chase the King away so
now I plays a 4 now if I'm gonna get to
play the move a 5 then my next move is
gonna be Knight b6 check why because I
have the opposition and the pawn is
gonna be they're gonna be king behind
this pawn so that's not gonna work
anymore so black is forced to play the
move a5 forced we cannot let the white
horn advance and let that night out
because this time the pond ending is
drawn as opposed to what we saw before
now what to do King c4 the only move
King c6 at first glance we look at this
position we think wow white is losing if
he moves his Knight is gonna lose it
when the King goes backwards we're just
gonna go King b7 take the knight say
thank you very much but in porn endings
there and in chess there's always
wonderful opportunities here he plays
Knight to c7 take my knight and he took
it what else the night is gonna roll
free now King b5 the only move to save
the pawn or else is Bishop to b6 and
just when it looks like black is
completely organized to win the game
white plays this little menacing move
King a6 and now the pawn can't move if
the bishop move I'm going to move
take the pawn on e5 if you move the King
I will take the bishop and the only move
to defend the bishop and move the King
leads to stalemate sir white gets his
draw beautiful composition when you
think about the minimalistic means here
just a pawn and a bit of minor piece to
each side and still so much so much
richness in it it's just I think I find
one of my beautiful month the most
beautiful simple combinations are should
I say compositions that I've seen with
only little material there's so much to
it upon ending the points appointing the
drawers and then a motif of still made
to save the draw
understood or questions okay so our last
position for the day is this one which
is number this is a toughy but beautiful
in my opinion again it demands knowledge
of King and pole endings there's no way
you can solve it if you do not know King
and colonies the way I described it
before so white looks like he is really
in trouble here not only is his Knight
pinned and about to be captured but this
Bishop might come here to the long
diagonal to add insult to injury and
skew the rock in the night so for
example if you go King g2 and I'm gonna
take take and then Bishop here you're
losing so still this is white to move
and draw in a real beautiful way very
impressive let me show you how it's done
I think you will enjoy it so step one
King g3 we must move away from the pin
because about to lose an idea Chuck now
if you try to play Bishop to b6 I'm
gonna grow 93 and I'm saving the game
you attack my rook I attack new rook if
you look at ax my knight I will defend
it each gonna have the same number of
pawn I'm in one point and one minor is
gonna be a drop so black needs to play
the only move that he has left rook
takes Knight just like before now what
to do we know that we cannot take
so what can we do again you might say oh
maybe the Rope can attack the bishop but
this is where it takes a lot more than
that he the game he goes luke h5 check
if he goes just look here oops sorry
if he just goes here then I just go here
guess what I'm just defending my stop so
now so you gotta go rook to h5 check
what is the point of this
the idea is to lift the King to the
third rank reasons of which you will see
in a second now if you go away I'm just
going to take this rook white is gonna
win this game
so you've gotta attack my rock and now
I'm attacking your bishop now if you
move your rock I'll take the bishop it's
a draw so you must play the only move
that you have and I'm gonna go rook d6
Jack and the King is gonna climb up very
important to be up because we're
expecting upon ending and now rook takes
b6 and now both rooks are hanging if you
take my rook I'll take you rock
so black says hey guess what I might as
well suck my rock before I lose it right
that this get the pawn for it and he
goes rook takes f3 check and now you
think wait a minute what just happened
after King takes rook eight takes b6 who
is the opposition black he's gonna win
the game and therefore white plays King
GTO a beautiful elegant little move he's
saying no I'm not taking your rook of
course now if black moves his rook white
moves his rook it's a very simple drawn
rook component me because it's a rook
pawn no way you can win it and of course
after takes now I take and who is the
opposition now why does and he draws
because now is the king in front of his
pawn is this understood I know it's hard
let's take it from the top one time I
think it's really really nice and worth
it after King g3 he has to take white
cannot afford to attack the bishop at
once because the bishop just defends the
king he's got a lured up King to the
third rank then we attacked the bishop
the bishop defends the rock his only
move
and now check the King knows to go up if
you went down then he would lose every
porn ending so you would have any chance
to win so here check and again white
plays a very smart move
King G - he knows he cannot afford to
lose the opposition he's got a lure
black to take first when black takes
first we take the rock and draw okay
that's all I have for tonight hope you
guys enjoyed it until next time